[Music]
honesty is key wheels on the bus I just
question must come out Oh
Reis palette I didn't even know what
keys was gonna come out a man is
threatening to sue his wife for
revealing his tiny secret I heard
Chinese secret tiny secret on ready you
ready how dare you tell the world my
dick is small he has little earlobes and
he doesn't like it
yeah he like pushes his hand I think he
has a big [ __ ] dick but the hole is
small so he takes a long pee
this is super strong yes oh god it hurts
so much he cleans like all the [ __ ]
crust it's so much pressure on family
got the other night there's literally
like Peter Griffin was like yeah I feel
good right now cuz I just I got some of
the poop off the side of toilet with my
pee so I can do service yeah I do it has
a charity service at the public restroom
no for real
I'm always like judging to like you guys
are so filthy I have to come in and do
this in the public restrooms yeah well
you can get the public was like yeah I
did that you're welcome I'll do that huh
yeah and that's why I cracked up well
Family Guy cuz I was like man it's the
[ __ ] that you think like oh it's just me
like I was like man you guys are smart
how do you guys feel when you've been
aiming at that and then it's like parts
are crumbling off and then just at that
last piece that's still there and you
don't get fish I had a little more pee
yeah I'm like a little more another day
and if it was a little hotter it would
have melted it right on yeah but I felt
my Pete was a little too cold
sometimes I flushed a couple times and
shagging yeah you you can sports more
Pia well I may I come back to it you
know yeah all right she wrote about her
husband's micro penis on reddit Oh
secret well then why would you why would
you sue we read it you can't sue for the
truth okay so she posted it on the
subreddit called m.i.b [ __ ] so she
started yes she definitely is well hold
on to your hair
so she says the title is newlywed
husband 32 male wanted to wait till
marriage for sex I'm just surprised me
27 female with micro penis on the
honeymoon he legit has micro penis it's
an inch and a half erect so if you I
don't know micro penis is a legit
condition the Howard Stern Show is where
I saw it
that shit's small that's just almost
like my pinky what it's like
no no micro penis is is inch-and-a-half
erect yeah I've seen it yeah you're
right the Howard Stern episode there's
like guys with micro penis what am i 4
or 5 yeah that [ __ ] it's crazy just get
butt-ass naked it's kind of interesting
first of all I think it's [ __ ] up that
that's the medical term for it Michael
penis I'm saying like we did all these
like out of all the names for diseases
like [ __ ] like I don't know like
jaundice and like gonorrhea you're like
art man this man has a really small
penis let's call it micro penis why
couldn't they call her like Johnson's
disease or something like Johnson Seto
yeah Jon coz she's saying am i [ __ ] up
because he surprised me with the micro
dick on my way she still [ __ ] up
they're both [ __ ] up for sure so she
said this so we only dated for six
months we've been engaged for another
six and just got married on Saturday
I literally just got back from my
honeymoon a couple hours ago my husband
isn't a religious guy he just says the
old fashioned like that we got close to
fooling around a couple times but it
never went far I tried but he has always
stopped it after it went too far anyway
she tried dry humping and when she
realized there's no [ __ ] hard dick
there he knew what the [ __ ] he was doing
[ __ ] cat dictor dude yeah he did
Victor did CAD dick everything she got
engaged in six months of dating I know
right and then they were engaged for six
months so like so they dated for six
months and then got engaged for six
months so only one year and they got
married
they're from Ohio Midwest fools they
date for like three months and they're
engaged ready or military guys military
[ __ ] eighteen-year-old military boys
they want to get married already as soon
as they turn like this right what'd she
say what'd she say she said am I the
[ __ ] for reading into this and being
upset that I waited until my wedding
night to find out that he probably isn't
as old-fashioned as he says you I'm not
going to shame him and honestly I don't
even know how I'll I'll broach the topic
I'm not seeking advice in parenthesis I
honestly just acted like nothing was out
of the ordinary and went went to town
with him but that's time I kind of feel
lied to like a half-truth or something
Montana we held withheld from booking
suck the [ __ ] out of that straw huh what
if she was just trying to like suck on
it to see if it'll get bigger in her
mouth just get some migraines
yeah and if I popped out like oh well
there it is
is he also a larger man I wonder I don't
know buddy
what do you girls think you guys think
you guys would have been lied to or like
what if he just was uncomfortable about
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah well it's divorced
she confronted him about it and so she
said like you know why didn't you tell
me and then he said well I didn't want
to tell you because I didn't want you to
leave me oh so he did lie yeah we had
bad intentions cuz if he was out in the
open like yo I had this name kind of
embarrassed about and if he was open
about it it gives the girl a chance to
be exciting right yeah cuz there's guys
that had like dick problems and then
like it got like dick dick amputated you
know like there's stories we heard guys
that knew how to [ __ ] it we know what
you're talking about like they they know
how to eat [ __ ] rail good or whatever
and he has no problems like you know
getting that on with ladies and [ __ ]
right so there are forgiving ladies I
think this is more of a
it's like more ethics like you live man
like great worm and miss Andy yeah yeah
what's bad great from Game of Thrones
like great worms like you know Greyjoy
great warrior on soldier soldier and the
translator girl the slave guy slave
soldier yeah okay cuz like you know she
knew what was up and he was like my they
still love each it's to love each other
they're like how do you get it on
remember that seem to they're like yeah
but they've got it on though they did
get it on
she got a big old smile yeah he was
eating the poon yeah but like this guy
it's [ __ ] up cuz I feel like he didn't
even give her a chance to make a
decision what kind of sucks is this guy
is probably gonna walk away from the
relationship thinking oh [ __ ] me was the
micropenis the whole time not knowing
that the truth is that it's cuz he lied
it's also because of the micropenis he
should have developed I should have
developed a technique where he could
[ __ ] stimulate the [ __ ] out of her
[ __ ] with his little dick so the
original poster she kept posting on some
updates and so one of them was what I
said which was that she confronted him
and he said apparently he found out that
she posted on reddit because no friend
of his that knows about as microfiche
that also saw on Facebook that he
recently got married and then he shared
this read a post with him and that's how
he found out so the husband got so mad
thank you he's like oh you know I'm
gonna I want an annulment and I'm gonna
sue you for defamation of character
because it's only a matter of time
that's not defamation she didn't even
put his name in it though it's not deaf
mating because it's the truth exactly it
will only be deaf mating if you had a
[ __ ] regular Johnson and then she's
spreading all these rumors and it's
preventing him and [ __ ] up his
reputation even if it's if it's if it
has to be not true
yeah if it's true then it's not what do
you do facing woody defaming so she also
posted on the same so read it in my the
[ __ ] for telling him it's not okay to
take out a second mortgage so he can get
phalloplasty oh man
he took out at [ __ ] at least did he
tell her he asked so he so she continued
as he scheduled a free consultation with
a plastic surgeon but told me it's
probably gonna cost at least 50 K Wow DK
for a bigger day he'll expensive that's
not even fair I think it sounds like
she's more upset at his decisions in how
he tackles problems then his little dick
yeah this was so stupid he's like [ __ ]
man give me problems right it's just as
idiot brain I remember when we were
doing asked it feels like every time
someone submitted questions without fail
there's always a guy asking if his big
is big enough right 99% of it's always a
dick related question like is she gonna
love me mm-hmm is she gonna like me is
she gonna is she gonna be happy with the
I don't know if my dicks big enough it's
like three inches hard that's crazy they
put so much of a emphasis on their dick
right it's like they sit there and look
at their dick and [ __ ] like watching
porn all day - and I compare you to that
amore sting and that horse make is scary
guys but there's other things like
[ __ ] get your finances set [ __ ]
learn how to dress your hygiene [ __ ]
exercise like learn to be emotionally
intelligent funny be fun there's so many
things that you need to work on and you
just sitting there
[ __ ] fiddling your [ __ ] dick all
day like [ __ ] is it [ __ ] good enough
exactly it's gonna [ __ ] you up yeah poor
dick you scared poor dick is scary
pointing point out all these hugs guys
heads up I think it [ __ ] girls heads up
too because like girls that like let's
say you're you're like a like you
haven't had sex yet and you're only
watching porn oh yeah [ __ ] you guys if
you read comments right like slip
Singapore no listen listen I'm not
stopping haunting me
i'ma save our main eruption
you have the floor yeah Oh
like if you let's say a guy post a
picture on Instagram some [ __ ] is you
kind of see the dick print you see such
a wide spectrum of comments which there
were some people are like yeah a wide
spectrum of comments where some are like
oh man shrimp dick and where other girls
and the other girls are like oh wow
looking good that's a good size but like
because like I feel like sometimes girls
will see a huge dick but because they
watch too much porn they're like Oh
shrimp dick he doe got that there right
and it works the same way where I've
seen Wow
no no for real cuz like um I think Rick
told me that a homegirl of his we saw
some we saw some [ __ ] leaked sex tape
and miracle like then dude his dude is
like packing right and this girl was
like oh he and I got a big date was like
the what kind of dicks are you trying do
you think are like big dicks yeah well
maybe her whole huge she's just
envisioning it she's bagging gonna work
the picture with booties too long with
that credit so there's a girl in high
school who I don't think she was really
experienced but she used to always talk
like she was and so like when she would
talk about like dick sizes right she
goes oh I wanna I want at least like an
8-inch dick all right oh my god please
stop so we're okay so what's the 8-inch
dick to you right does she measure from
the [ __ ] to the tip inches six inches
how much is this this is like eight or
ten that's not saying he's not hip let
him talk beside so you know what she
said right here this is what this is
what I'm saying
yeah like the perception is off yeah I
was just trying to measure with my
fingers so she was like so she other
what's the a distinct she's like oh like
this big I think you don't know so you
don't saying so like yeah but then
perception wise is different yeah yeah I
mean so what she was aborted different
she thought was the image dick was just
a regular like five inch dick I was like
it's not even a nice dick was a five
inch dick what are you talking about I
love the passion here with
have to have it accurate no no no you
have an accurate measurement all right
you know an accurate measurements no
dude you gotta go for the base if you go
to the buccal lay back and let it go
this way and your fat down a little bit
yeah you gotta put your shape down and
you got to make sure there's no bigger
objects around you look at the
difference this is probably more of a
realistic measurement of an eighth inch
and a 6 inch you also have petite hands
though so I have woman hands so it's a
better better idea of how it [ __ ] 806
inch be like so this girl I used to miss
to the girls like tallest like 510 like
511 is right and she also like huge
hands so whenever she would be like I
have my dick her hands like mine she
looks tiny right now I think I recorded
at one site and she also had like a big
mouth so like how do I would like I
recorded her like one time like you know
give me a head whatever I was watching
it back I was like if this ever leaks
people don't think my dick is super tiny
because her hands and mouth it's so big
cuz I like this you ready Tim you ready
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]